thank you jc las vegas territory and the
fire light barn have teamed up to take
you beyond the neon
and into the wild wild west for
valentine's day let's head to firelight
barn
[Music]
we are here at the firelight barn dinner
theater in henderson
and we began as a family band about 20
years ago
and we've performed all over the nation
we've performed in 49 states
canada and europe we decided to open up
here in henderson
and provide a place for locals to have
live music entertainment without having
to deal with all of the craziness of the
strip
so our band is called mama's wranglers
and i'm the mama and then
the wranglers are my children
[Music]
back and forth and saddle on a horse
that is incubated
there's such a funny minute
[Music]
our show that's running in the theater
right now is called
the good the bad and the wranglers and
it's a real fun
classic assortment of good western music
but also
a little doo-wop a little this a little
rock and roll
[Music]
so we serve barbecue and we figured with
our old time western music that we play
barbecue goes right
hand in foot with that
[Music]
that's the joy that we get is to see
people tapping their feet and clapping
along
or even trying to yodel we're going to
invite rocky from las vegas now up on
stage with us
give her a big hand oh my gosh hi
okay what am i doing i'm going to teach
you how to yodle today
okay so all it is is just a
you start on lower notes
you know where the like word yodel is
when you actually
yodel while yodeling you say the word
[Music]
can i be a part of the band now kinda
send mom kinda
oh okay it's a whole other beast when
you add music
and you keep going there's no way i took
only one person
wow that was fun thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]
whoa yeah
all right catch their valentine's themed
show purdy hitched
and to see what's open beyond the neon
with las vegas territory visit
explore.lasvegas.territory.com
okay